now governor steve sisilak republican
candidates for governor and city leaders
are all renewing calls to break up the
clark county school district so today
during a one-on-one sit down with
superintendent dr jesus jarrah this
morning politics now host john langler
asked him exactly about that possibility
should it be broken up the idea of
breaking up ccsd is not a new topic of
conversation
why should ccsd stay as it is yeah so
actually that's been a topic of
discussion for
over two decades
in clark county i can tell you there's
large urban districts that are
outperforming us that are bigger than we
are
um it's not an issue of size
i think it's an issue of
lack of systems in the clark county
school district ourselves
you know we
may have not been focused on the right
work and doing the right things
and those are some of the things that we
have been putting in place
for the last three years um so but
that's up to uh that's up to the
governor and the voters and and
well
others to decide well let me ask you
this then okay say you know governor
sissellac uh all the others who are
running for governor they've at least
suggested they're open to the idea how
do you convince them
not to do it that the best way forward
is is as is
i think um you know
it sounds good right you know well let's
let's let's let's
open and look and see what i can tell
you um when you look at and breaking it
up i think the inequities are going to
be exacerbated even more than what kovit
exposed
um you're going to have pockets
that there's going to be
more poverty the more you know the the
socio-economic the student demographic
is going to be um it's going to be
exposed um and i think that's that's a
concern for ch for children
um you know if we're really looking at
if we're looking at addressing the issue
we're still going to have
pockets where there's going to be
lack of teachers there's going to be
high class sizes breaking up the
district is not going to address the
immediate needs that our children need
which is lower class size
we need teachers and classrooms
that are delivered in a high quality
curriculum you can be at a large school
system you can be a medium size you can
be at a large size school system those
the root cause is still going to be
there
dr jarrow also pointing out that the
last time they started an academic year
fully staffed was back in 1994. you can
watch more of that interview coming up
on 8 news now at 6.